let's try this okay right can we solve
this at the moment just as it's written
what what sort of tools do you have in
your disposal to solve this any
suggestions okay now I could I mean I've
got all this modern form stuff written
on the board okay and there's a good
reason for that but I think I need to
appeal to monarchy form just yet
do I like it's fairly small numbers
can't I do something else with it
so if I write it like so this is the
difference of cubes right and I know how
to factorize the difference of cubes I
can do that this is if you remember the
science right it's gonna be same
opposite always positive okay so I have
this factorization now if we were in the
real number field right usually at this
point I would stop there's nothing I can
do with that thing over there on the
right but I'm not in the real lava field
right like I can go further than this
this thing I can do a linear
factorization I can always do a linear
factorization because I'm in the
corporate world right so let's just do
one piece at a time
what solution do I get out of this but
out of this guy excuse me I can either
complete square or I can just jump in
and I can do the formula right that'll
give me a solution it's gonna have
complex solutions but that's fine I can
do with those so I'm gonna say is
there's two holes right fill me out
quadratic formula minus B plus or minus
B squared minus AC you carry that both
of which one and then on the denominator
I have 2a which is 2 okay
remember that so this is minus 1 1 so
minus what's underneath the square root
it's negative 3 so I'm gonna rewrite
that with my you know I've got imaginary
units right so I'm going to say that's
the square root of 3 that's how many
months have I I have right that's the
square of negative 3 there that's all
divided by 2
happy with that
now I have three answers here I have 300
I've got one and then I've got two three
sitting in there okay how do I know
whether I'm right or not I could just
keep the thing right like that one's me
tibial do I think you this and I'm going
to I can tell you right now you you'll
come back to one okay so I have three
cube roots now this is interesting
though one of the great things about
what art form is that once you've right
some people at home you can see it more
clearly because you can say oh I'm this
far away and I want to go that far
around okay so let's put these guys on a
1 2 3 complex numbers I can plot them as
points let's go ahead and do that yeah
if you excuse me you cannot manipulate
this in a variety of ways that should be
able to show that it satisfies this
okay now what I'm going to do to help us
plot this right is been in there are
three routes I'm going to designate them
three different names so I can
distinguish them so I'll call them Z 1
and Z 2 and dead 3 ok with that
now zip one's easy I'm gonna pop you
just call that one so there's my cell 1
now what we have a look is there Tunes
at 3 if we pop these in one art form
we'll be able to work out where these
are and then get a picture of what's
happening so how do I convert this
somewhat odd form what am I gonna do
with it I'm gonna have to split out the
real and imaginary parts right so for
example if I go we'll take the negative
case purse okay so we'll go minus 1
minus root 3 and that's both on - do you
agree with that okay so to work out the
modulus of Z - modulus of Z - ok that's
the square root of square root of what
there's the real part squared which is
1/4 and then there's the imaginary part
squared which is 3/4 yes
square root of 1 that's just 1 right
okay there's the modulus what about the
arguments let's call it theta - right
how am I going to get that remember what
we round this this morning right you
want your real and imaginary parts to
keep my real pot cause all Thea 2 is
going to be minus 1 on 2 right and sine
of theta 2 is minus root 3 or 2 anyone
tell me what the answer is
we already know it's going to be in the
third quadrant right because of where
the numbers are minus 1/2 minus root 3
on 2 so it's down here then you think
about well okay what angle is going to
correspond to that over here minus minus
2 minus 2 pi on 3 which I can tell he's
about there ok so from these two I gain
that equals -2 PI 3 that's my principle
argument
a little bit yes I mean you're gonna see
it pretty immediately like in about two
minutes but I'm not going to do the
formal yet so this is two and this my
angle they're too high on the three but
it's negative
that's why I've gone clockwise okay now
I could go through this whole process
again this process here to get Zed
three-in-one art form I can but I'm not
going to write because z2 and z3 are
actually very very closely related right
what's the relationship between sentence
and three can you see that they are
conjugates of each other you see that
right like the first one was minus 1
minus returning on to I and the next one
will replace that with a plus it's just
the conjugate so geometrically where's
the conjugate from said to go in here on
my diagram
it's just up it's reflected across the
real axis right so I'm gonna go up here
okay so I'm just writing that to
indicate how I know it's up there right
I got from here and I just took the
reflection okay and that goes off
because it's the reflection the argument
here is - 2 pi/3 so what's the argument
of zip right just 2 pi/3 just a pleasant
one going right ok now we don't need it
to work out where the location of this
thing is but is what angle at the origin
that I'm missing here tell me what it is
this guy this guy here right well if
they all add up to 2 pi right that's
adding up to 6 pi + 3 all I've got two
here and two here so it's left every is
super great okay so how would you in
words describe z1 z2 and z3 how far they
all from the origin they're all do you
think they're all one unit away so in
fact I can put my unit circle on here
I'm just going to do that in a dotted
line like so mouth so you can see all of
the roots are on the unit circle and
they're not just anywhere on the root
unit circle right
what's the relationships between two
different tables so I can think about
this I can say okay they're 120 degrees
apart they're 2 pi/3 radians apart but
more specifically they're just equi
distant in terms of their angles right
they're equally equally spaced out
around the circumference excuse me of
the unit circle okay in fact I'm gonna
write that z1 z2 and z3
spaced out nobody think about this and
you think geometrically again about what
it means to cube these public spaces
right you can see it has to be that way
it has to be that way it right for
instance let's think about the first
solution okay the first solution that's
just one okay not very good you see when
you keep one the fit 1 times 1 is 1 and
then 1 times 1 times 1 is still 1 so
that doesn't go anywhere okay that's the
multiplicative identity you just
multiply it by itself it stays put
doesn't go anywhere but then when you
come to this guy right what happens when
we multiply three times well the first
modification will get you there
right what will happen to the next
multiplication you add the arguments so
you land here and then the third
multiplication takes you to one which of
course is where I wanted to end up right
and of course z2 down here does the
exact same thing but it doesn't in
Reverse right it goes clockwise there's
the first multiplication then there's
the second multiplication and then
there's the third one it takes you back
to one which is the number I'm trying to
find them does that make sense